taking his fifth start on the euro 1-0
record 398 era for done and 20 and a
third he has 13 walks want to stay away
from the walk 16 strikeouts orioles a
5-3 winner last night first game of the
series they wrap it up tomorrow
afternoon it's a four-pitch walk and
mullins on board for the orioles done
last year he allowed 13 stolen bases
last year as a starting pitcher that was
the most in the american league so you
got to think the orioles will be trying
to take an extra 90. there he goes right
on cue
won't even throw it down there
breaking ball had a big jump cedric
mullins as his third stolen base of the
year good man
got him that's a big strikeout two down
he needed that
1-1
hanging up
for dylan moore
a little bit of a scare in the first
inning no harm done jorge lopez five
starts on the year elevated era 21 and
two thirds innings pitch he can strike
you out though 21 punch-outs
roller to galvez hustles to the cross
one down
so you say he's scuffling right down to
franco
two down
wow seeger down on strikes
so a very efficient one two three
innings
that one is a little high ball four so
another lead off walk for the orioles
here
breaking ball strike three goal
looks like he wants it in here
got a lot of the plate and base face it
into right field
more up with it
and dj stewart stops at second so a
couple of orioles on with one down
down low and he lost him second walk of
the inning and the orioles have him
loaded
swing and a miss he struck him out
needed it two outs it's a fourth
strikeout we're done he gets ahead with
the breaking ball and he comes right
back 94 miles an hour probably middle in
throws it by him dan the 1-1 on the way
to mullins and here she comes swinging a
ground ball wide at first evan white is
there thunder and flipped it done at the
bag and it's in time to get mullins holy
smokes and justin dunn walks that tight
rope and he gets to the other side
the 3-2 swinging a fly ball down the
right field line it's going to be a fair
ball in toward the corner up of the ball
now as dj stewart gets a throw in cut
off by ruiz the second baseman luis
terence with a one-out single and
there's the first change up
bounce to the right side
no problem for ruiz the outed first and
the mariners retired in the second we're
heading to the third
that's swinging a miss on the breaking
ball that was a slider that time fifth
strikeout
first pitch drives moore back he's got
some room not much but he's got room and
he jumps
like he was gonna be at the edge of the
track in front and then it kept drifting
on
little breeze blowing out towards right
and i think he gave us some extra carry
dylan even thought that he was going to
be camped underneath it but i had to
jump
blind left field back is austin hayes
and he gloves it two down
2-2 he got him
at the knees how do you do so down in
order go to the mariners
again good stuff quick two outs
now the wind-up and the 0-2 pitch
swing and it's popped up
right side of home plate off of the mask
is torenzier the dugout here comes evan
white it's evan white who makes the
catch right at the railing of the
mariners first base dugout and that will
be it for the birds in the top of the
fourth inning 2-2 to tie france
he got him rants down looking here is
kyle seeger the wind up and the three to
the kyle swung on it belted deep to
right field going going goodbye baseball
a rocket into the lower deck and right
kyle seeger with his fifth home run of
the season and he gives the mariners a
one-nothing lead here in the bottom of
the fourth
[Applause]
3-2 pitch threw it by him at 96. so two
strikeouts in the inning mariners do
break the tie with a seeger home run one
nothing they're down it'll send up rio
ruiz who was a strikeout victim the
first time that he was up
ruiz big blast
way back
way back and
almost into the second deck
so rio who's struck out with the bases
loaded his last at bat gets it on the
barrel this time and we're tied at one
how about you
mr ruiz
two balls no strikes
crawford running and they got him
another one make it five out of six for
chance cisco
j.p crawford's going to test cisco he
got a pretty good jump but i'm going to
tell you jorge lopez did a pretty good
job getting it down there what a throw
by chance cisco one game last night
orioles won five to three here's the
pitch and it's outside for ball four so
the mariners have a runner back on it
first
the other way nicely done beating the
ship
the two speed guys on the base path now
here comes the bullpen in platko
2-2 little bouncer pletco gloves it
flips it to mancini and they get the out
so the mariners strand two that stays in
the path of the baseball a long time
it's not a big launch angle stroke so
straight to it and believe it or not
trey mancini right there he doesn't have
a big launch angle he doesn't have a big
uppercut swing he gets a lot of ground
balls a lot of line drives a lot of
throws over there see if he'll be moving
3-2 not going
and he lost him missed by a foot or two
stadium coach so dunn leaves in a 1-1
game couple of them in the board one out
sixth inning
[Applause]
that's what he did but down low at 99
and the bases are loaded
[Applause]
the pitch to cisco swinging a broken
back soft hopping ground ball here comes
jp crawford shortstop cuts it off midway
onto first he throws and it is picked by
evan white at the bag and cisco is
retired to get the mariners out of the
jam in the top of the sixth inning
extended to sitting straight to four
games
it's this one gives it a ride deep left
center field
off the fence
louise digging for second and he'll get
there standing a lead off ringing double
[Applause]
who would buy him a fastball at 93 big
strikeout
here we go again 1-2
and he got him the tag from cisco so no
throw required down to first paul frye
comes in and gets back to back
strikeouts
in hard into left field tray mancini's
got a base hit to start the oriole
eighth
little roller gonna have trouble
he's there an infield hit ryan
montcastle can get down the line 1-1
ball game eighth inning two out bases
loaded
and he's going to get it done ty france
over to evan white ending over
the joseph stranded ten men tonight
meredith needs some runs here
louise takes over third with valencia to
second right field will it get down it
dies
fast runner at first base good start to
the eighth inning
three two pitch
takes for a ball for the loaded for kyle
seeger
1-0 to kyle screaming liner center field
hagerty tags here he comes the throw
goes to third kyle seeger's checked in
again 2-1 lead mariners in the eighth
second rbi tonight for six here is
center fielder kyle lewis and the marin
is now looking to add on one out drives
this one
right field that's got carrie again
a three-run jack by kyle lewis
and the mariners have exploded here in
the eighth inning
it's a four pitch walk
ouch
line drive base hit trey mancini's got
himself a three-hit knight and an rbi as
ruiz comes home robert duggar went to
the breaking ball one too many times
trey mancini too good of a hitter
weak line drive it'll fall in
and the orioles will get the tying run
to the plate mancini over to third
may have broke the bat but he kept the
game alive pat valleca well done
game on the line 1-2 pitch
him in struck him out mariners win it
five to two of the big four run eighth
inning explosion sack fly by seeger
three-run homer by kyle lewis
well nice
to see that mariner offense wake up late
and the bullpen as they have done all
season long able to hold it down